okay here we go hey palsies my name's
cody and i'm a helpster that means a
monster who helps and because i love
love love to help people so much i'm
making these videos called
helpsters help you
if you know me you know i love to make a
plan it's the best way to figure out how
to do something
but guess what sometimes something
happens and you have to change your plan
mm-hmm like today i was supposed to go
to the park to see my favorite tree a
cherry blossom tree except i found out
the park
is closed
i
know right but then i asked myself hey
cody yes cody is there another way to
see your favorite tree whoa whoa whoa
whoa what if you made your favorite tree
you mean like out of paper and stuff yes
i do i love that idea thank you so much
yes you're great you're great too
so that is the new goal make my favorite
treat so i can see it job one get paper
cut the paper into the shapes i need
oh by the way if you do this make sure
you get a grown-up to help okay
cut cut and job two done
and the third and final job glue it all
together
okay looks like all the jobs are done
because
here is my tree
oh it is so beautiful and lifelike and
you know if i use my imagination i can
almost smell the cherry blossoms
[Music]
you know you can do almost anything if
you use your imagination
you can even imagine yourself in
different places like
antarctica
whoa
will you look at that
oh hey
hey i'm gonna go play with those
penguins over there but i'll be back
real soon and until then see what you
can do to help the people and the
monsters around you because everyone
loves a helping hand bye
hey wait for me
hamsters
help you